The wildly talented cast of Knives Out consists
of former superheroes, super spies, and a
few legendary Hollywood superstars like Jamie
Lee Curtis, Don Johnson, and Michael Shannon
— to name only a few!
But where have you seen the rest of these
familiar faces before?
Well, here's a handy who's who for Rian Johnson's
whodunnit, Knives Out.
Unless you've been living under a rock for
the past decade, chances are good that you're
familiar with Daniel Craig and his prestigious
body of work.
The English actor's breakout role was that
of the iconic 00 Agent, James Bond, in 2006's
Casino Royale.
It was a role that, thanks to multiple sequels,
landed him on Forbes' World's Highest Paid
Actors list in 2015.
However, the handsome Brit is far from a one-trick
pony.
Over the years, Craig has excelled in a vast
array of genres, ranging from dramas like
2002's Oscar-winning Road to Perdition to
comedies like 2017's Logan Lucky.
In Knives Out, Craig plays Benoit Blanc, a
private detective brought on to investigate
the death of famous crime novelist Harlan
Thrombey.
"I suspect foul play.
I have eliminated no suspects."
Craig was actually the first actor to sign
on to the project, and he was apparently flattered
to have been offered the part.
As he explained to Cinema Blend,
"I hadn't read something like that before,
and I was just over the moon that [Johnson]
offered it to me."
With a lead like Craig, it's no mystery why
so many critics are crazy about Knives Out.
Agatha Christie lovers ... assemble!
Although the MCU's Captain America obviously
won't be making an appearance in Johnson's
murder mystery, Chris Evans, who's played
the star-spangled Avenger several times since
2011's Captain America: The First Avenger,
will be.
The Boston-bred hunk has flexed his dramatic
ability in films like Before We Go and Gifted,
but not as often as he's flexed his impressive
physique in action flicks The Losers and Scott
Pilgrim vs. the World.
With an apparent affinity for playing "the
good guy," Evans has played not one but two
different superheroes, first starring as the
Human Torch in the Fantastic Four franchise.
His role of Ransom Drysdale in Knives Out,
however, will be quite the opposite.
Evans told Entertainment Weekly:
"I'm usually tasked with playing guys who
are a little more noble, and this guy is a
little bit more vile.
It's fun."
Although it didn't exactly light up the box
office, 1992's The Efficiency Expert, starring
acting legends like Anthony Hopkins and Russell
Crowe marked the film debut of Toni Collette.
In the decades to come, the Australian actress
would enjoy a highly successful career, most
evidenced by her massive award-season love.
In 2009, she was cast as the lead role in
Showtime's United States of Tara.
As Tara, a mother coping with dissociative
identity disorder, Collette earned wins at
both the Golden Globes and the Emmys.
On the big screen, the actress has excelled
in dramatic comedies like Little Miss Sunshine
and About a Boy.
However, she's perhaps most recognized for
her work in a pair of iconic horror flicks:
1999's unforgettably twisty The Sixth Sense
and 2018's disturbingly dark Hereditary.
In Knives Out, the decorated actress plays
Joni Thrombey, a "lifestyle guru" and daughter-in-law
of murder victim Harlan Thrombey.
When speaking to Deadline, Collette showered
the murder mystery's script with praise, saying,
"It was all in the writing.
In reading it, it just kept opening up and
changing, and it was so swift, and so smooth,
and so surprising."
What Katherine Langford's filmography lacks
in quantity, it makes up for in quality.
At the ripe age of 20, the young Australian
actress landed the role of ill-fated high
school student Hannah Baker in the Netflix
smash series 13 Reasons Why.
Langford stole the show as Hannah, even earning
a Golden Globe nomination for her performance.
Her newfound stardom landed her parts in two
movies in 2018, The Misguided and Love, Simon.
"Oh my God.
Have you guys seen Creek Secrets today?"
Although she'd previously worked with some
fairly big names, Langford was admittedly
quite starstruck when seeing her Knives Out
co-stars in action.
She told Yahoo! TV:
"I get so in awe of everyone.
... I've watched all of these people."
While sharing the screen with A-listers like
Daniel Craig and Chris Evans must've been
incredible, the young starlet, who plays Meg
Thrombey in the whodunnit, went on to specifically
give praise to her fellow Aussie actress.
Calling Toni Collette a, quote, "legend,"
she claimed that working with her was "amazing."
Although her official acting debut came in
a Spanish film in 2006, Ana de Armas' Hollywood
career really started in 2015, starring alongside
Keanu Reeves as Bell in the dark thriller
Knock Knock.
After that, she played Miles Teller's girlfriend,
Iz, in War Dogs, and then the holographic
Joi in the trippy Blade Runner 2049.
Although she's starring alongside Daniel Craig
in 2020's new Bond film, No Time to Die, the
gorgeous Cuban starlet first shared the screen
with him in Knives Out.
As Marta Cabrera, the recently deceased Harlan
Thrombey's live-in nurse, de Armas is one
of the prime murder suspects.
But while de Armas admittedly had a wonderful
experience on set, shooting in Boston had
one particular downside.
She explained:
"It was my first time in Boston.
It was freezing, for a Cuban especially."
The actress may have been cold, but is she
actually Knives Out's cold-blooded killer?
Life has been especially good for Lakeith
Stanfield over the past ten years.
The California-raised actor's first big break
was getting cast as Marcus in Short Term 12,
alongside Brie Larson.
He then was cast as Jimmie Lee Jackson in
2014's Oscar-winning Martin Luther King Jr.
biopic, Selma.
Since then, his career has really caught fire.
Although he's appeared in popular films like
Get Out, Sorry to Bother You, and Netflix's
Death Note, perhaps his most recognizable
role is that of the philosophical stoner Darius
in Donald Glover's comedic drama Atlanta.
"Not all great things come from great pain.
Sometimes, it's love.
Not everything's a sacrifice."
For Knives Out, Stanfield is playing Lieutenant
Elliot, a detective investigating Harlan Thrombey's
death.
Though he initially thinks that the victim
took his own life, more clues begin to surface
— and his character starts to suspect something
more sinister is afoot.
The award-winning actor will, much like the
audience, try to solve Rian Johnson's whodunnit.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.